[Applause]
[Music]
before we get started let's just pay the
bills right now
[Music]
Main Street boxing gym this is all the
main street fighters come from 100% as
you can see there's a lot of bags full
size ring the Olympic training a lot of
Champions came in and out of this place
come here and train young and old every
bag imaginable speed bag heavy bag full
body bag full size ring combat talk with
the King now that the fight is done the
victor has won now I guess the
controversy has begun in my opinion is
really isn't no controversy the
understand just like a Danny Garcia
versus Shawn Porter Shawn Porter became
the person he needs to become to win
that fight
all right skills can take you but so far
in this fight Canelo became exactly who
they said that he wasn't Spanish
Heritage Month started on the 15th and
he showed his pride he showed his pride
as a fighter he showed his heart as a
fighter he showed his courage to walk
through fire to get to a place with very
few fighters Kingo triple G in my
opinion was who he is triple G I told
you that he would pressure Canelo
I told you that he would walk them down
and win a split decision well that
didn't happen
Cannell had something to say about this
Canella heard all the talks about him
being a drug cheat allegedly Canela
heard all the talks about he didn't
fight traditional Mexican boxing style
which is you know stand there box it out
bang it out and give it all you got
blood guts and tears they attack the
man's pride my analysis of the fight is
Canelo decided to take that narrative
away from triple G from round one Canelo
decided to use his force and back up
triple G so you figured after the first
and second round okay
third round triple G kick it in and
start walking the young man down that's
not what happened
triple G decided to have a keep off me
jab fight off his back foot most of the
evening countering now in the 10th round
he mounted an offensive threat towards
Canelo now mind you up until this point
Canelo has been doing all the dictating
of the fight that's called ring
generalship ring generalship is scored
when it comes to judging all right so
anyone out here yelling fraud yelling
he's been robbed triple G wasn't wrong
you're not robbed when you have the
opportunity to knock out your opponent
you're not robbed when you have the
opportunity to lead you're not robbed
when you have the opportunity to take
your destiny into your hands
now if he did everything that he could
possibly do and you go to the scorecards
and we saw there was a clear concise
winner then you can say he was robbed he
was not robbed the person that was
pushing the pace for the evening was
Canelo the person that was working and
stalking the stalker was can
the person that showed great ring
generalship with Canelo the person that
looked like the aggressor and look like
that the champion was Canelo the person
that was backing up jabbing defensively
shooting right hands and waiting for
opportunity to become great instead of
kicking the door down to greatness and
become great with triple G sometimes we
need to wait for greatness that not
never comes so you must seize the moment
that's how fleeting boxing is you cannot
wait for the person to get tired you
must make them tired you can't wait for
the person to weaken you must make them
weak you can't wait for the person to
lead you must lead so there's no one to
blame
you know triple G lost a great fight and
it was a great fight was it the greatest
middleweight history no but it was an
action-packed banger that Canelo
answered every punch with a punch of his
own Canelo showed the maturity that you
will love to see from your fighters he
showed the heart the will to go into
that fire he went and slayed the dragon
so is that mystique of triple G the
knockout killer there no it's not and I
feel if they fight a third time Camilla
will not come out because he no longer
has that fear he lost that fear in the
first fight where he was backing up
majority to fight now he wasn't he
walked him down stayed in the center to
ring his ropes is back only touched the
ropes one or two times in this fight and
I was in the later rounds
I salute both fighters there's no losers
when you step into that ring and you
lace them up and you throw that
mouthpiece and you look
a man across them from you and you have
decided that you and him will lose brain
cells that night there's no losers only
winners but the ultimate winner was
Canelo I salute you sir for giving me
one hell of a great fight when I told
you was gonna be a sweet one oh how
sweet
[Applause]
[Music]